dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fare hmm
today we are going to crush some soda
cans in the footage that you see here
the animations are performed by an
already existing algorithm for theme
shared affirmations and for a complete
sensorial experience this piece of work
aims to synthesize sound for these
phenomena sounds for crumpling up all
kinds of candy raps foils and plastic
bags a lofty noble goal loving it
however this problem is extraordinarily
difficult the reason is that these
crumpling simulations are amazingly
detailed and even if we know all the
physical laws for the sound synthesis
which is already pretty crazy it would
still be a fruitless endeavor to take
into consideration every single thing
that takes place in the simulation we
have to come up with ways to cut corners
to decrease the execution time of our
algorithm running a naive exhaustive
search would take tens of hours for only
several seconds of footage and the big
question is of course what can we do
about it and before we proceed just a
quick reminder that the geometry of
these models are given by a lot of
connected points that people in computer
graphics like to call vertices the sound
synthesis takes place by observing the
changes in the stiffness of these models
which is the source of the crumpling
noise normally our sound simulation
scales with a number of vertices and it
is abundantly clear that there are
simply too many of them to go through
one by one to this end we should strive
to reduce the complexity of this problem
first we start with identifying and
discarding the less significant
vibration modes beyond that if in one of
these vertices we observe that a similar
kind of buckling behavior is present in
its neighborhood we group up these
vertices into a patch and we then forget
about the vertices and run the sound
synthesis on these patches and of course
the number of patches is significantly
less than the number of vertices in the
original model in this footage you can
see some of these patches and it turns
out that the execution time can be
significantly decreased by these
optimization
with these techniques we can expect
results in at least five times quicker
but if we are willing to introduce
slight degradation to the quality of the
sounds we can even go ten times quicker
with barely perceptible changes to
evaluate the quality of the solutions
there is a user study presented in the
paper and the pinnacle of all tests is
of course when we let reality be our
judge everything so far sounds great on
paper but how does it compare to what we
experience in reality Wow truly
excellent results suffice to say they
are absolutely crushing it and we
haven't even talked about stochastic
enrichment and how one of these problems
can be solved optimally via dynamic
programming if you are interested make
sure to have a look at the paper thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time
[Music]